[Music]
that is the worst
nexio i have ever seen
but anyway
no i i could have done a better job
welcome to the leftist eating itself i'm
your host fran drescher
tonight's episode the wokey pokey yes
it's the woke's only deflection to
ignore the virginia election first up
new york times column this morning down
warns dems that the losses will keep
coming if they keep embracing wokeness
while blaming the party for violating
the pledge to be cool calm and
reassuring following president trump but
some dems aren't listening texas
lieutenant governor candidate matthew
dowd declared sunday that jesus would be
accused of being woke if he were around
today which i have to say seems hard to
prove
but remember unlike the woke mob jesus
was always for forgiveness
so leave it to the only sensible
democrat to sum things up tulsi gabbard
recently spoke to the shadowy figure
known as hannity
we don't have leaders who actually
respect the american people who actually
respect us enough to listen to listen to
what parents are concerned about uh you
know their children and their education
to listen to the american people who are
sick and tired of the power elite trying
to tear us apart based on the color of
our skin
there is a woman after my heart and
possibly my job
i don't want her here anymore
so kat here i i mentioned this a lot i
said it on the fire is it possible to
reason with the woke if the woke
believes that the people trying to
reason with him aren't woke aren't
conscious so is this like a losing
proposition for people like maureen dowd
yeah it's it's crazy because you know
their whole view of every it's stupid
you know and it's not working but if
you're stupid and you think that you're
actually really smarter than everyone
else then there really is no reasoning
or talking with them and also why would
they give it up because they have these
little circles where they don't have to
like research or prepare or have actual
beliefs they just have to be like you're
a racist you're a sexist and they win
every time yeah that's a lot easier than
doing work i'm actually jealous right
because if i was woke i would my life
would be so much easier i would be
hanging around you that's for sure
patriots
i'm a patriot
i believe america is great this is a
great step in france
yeah oh look at me patriot awards
there's still tickets available by the
way
for the silver table for the silver
table uh you're right it's a it's a very
simple construct by which they get to
treat all of us as a group right
systemic racism it's not you white man
or black man are racist because of what
you say or do the entire system is in
one direction so i get to put you greg
as a white male
in a category and that is who you are to
be damned and by the way uh if as far as
jesus is concerned he did
walk on water which seems a little
anti-science
[Music]
which means the woke mob wouldn't really
be for that yeah not
i mean if he claimed that he can't be
with them that is true well in the
cultural appropriation of fish
everywhere obviously yes teaching
teaching what kind of guy walks on water
do you breathe water bro yeah
like true how many sea turtles have to
duck so you can walk yeah that is so
true
you know uh um
i didn't understand neither did i so you
know steve
i i am kind of i'm i'm interested in
locus and because it's such an easy
filter to put on everything because you
can pretty much link anything you want
like when there's an ideology yeah you
know that that can just you can include
in every facet of your life it's scary
it's a cult it's called behavior in a
way it's totally cult behavior and it's
perfect for them because it's totally
self-reinforcing if you're against it
that proves their point that you're a
racist exactly contained within it and
the thing that's also true about this
whole story is it's another example of
what you're saying at the beginning
about the media because they they
totally amplify and reinforce it so they
hear that this is the thing that the
democrats are coming out with okay so we
have to be on board we have to agree
with it we have to insist on it so the
speed with which that a couple of lines
about critical race theory is not taught
in schools suddenly every single person
every single person in the media was
saying the same thing but you are seeing
some people almost staged like a
political intervention there are people
like james carville and mooring dad that
are going uh can you guys
pump the brakes but it's impos i think
it's not i think it's just something
that has to be completely er like let go
into the ocean like dropping a frozen
blob does the environment have to pay
for our dumbassery listen this
wokism isn't new
america has had a long tradition of
morons and idiots and dumbassery and bad
ideas and that's why we came together as
a civilization to stop those things it's
always going to be there the difference
now is
someone has given the dummies the
microphone
so at some point someone goes i'll let
the adults take that because there's
nothing new you can connect ignorance to
anything i can win any argument i want
in this room with every one of you no
matter what the subject is pete asked me
any question
tyrus how dare you racist talk to me
like that you don't know me dog
he won but i wanted oh oh so you can't
respect my boundaries you're gonna keep
coming at me no but i just
so you you're gonna disrespect me like
that that's what i'm talking about every
time i come in this building got some
white guy telling me this and that gonna
act this way how dare you sir
oh what
i'm a champion
i'm sorry
that was dumb as hell i said
nothing but you said everything hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else